c'est l'heure du thread horreur du moins
j'espère que vous allez bien trois
histoires sympa des nouvelles mécaniques
je sais que vous n'aimez pas qu'on les
théâtres sont longues dans ces vidéos là
alors place tout de suite aux histoires
la première c'est l'histoire de lydia et
c'est une grande première dans
l'histoire des serait d'horreur ça se
passe sous l'eau tout ce qu'on la
thalasso phobies comme moi actuellement
on est mal
lydia vient des caraïbes et là bas entre
noël et le nouvel an ont fait
tranquillement de la plongée sa famille
elle avait donc prévu plusieurs sessions
de plongée et elle précise que sa
famille sont des plongeurs bien plus
expérimentée qu'elle est long même
passer leurs niveaux de plongée ça veut
dire qu'ils peuvent aller plus profond
qu'elle a des profondeurs ou du coup
quand tu remontes tu dois attendre à des
paliers de décompression tout ça vous le
savez pas ce que vous avez vu cette
vidéo tu l'as pas vu lydia elle c'est
plutôt une plongeuse occasionnels elle
aime bien ça mais elle n'est pas
spécialiste
alors un jour elle décide de faire un
petit cours privés avec un instructeur
pour prendre en niveau et pouvoir
ensuite faire des plongée plus profonde
et compris avec sa famille sur le bateau
de lydia n'y a que des débutants c'est
même elle la plus expérimentée du bateau
et s'apprête à plonger dans un récif de
corail sublime bref tu connais les
caraïbes
il ya le petit briefing de sécurité et
tout le monde comprend bien les règles
dans le briefing évidemment il est
indiqué comment communiquer sous l'eau à
savoir via des signes donc on apprend
qu'elle signe correspond à quoi et puis
tout le monde commence tranquillement à
descendre 1,12 m tout se passe
merveilleusement bien mais faut quand
même noter quelque chose c'est que ce
jour là c'est une journée venteuse
il ya une forte houle alors c'est moins
relou quand et sous l'eau que quand tu
es à la surface mais du coup quand et
sous l'eau il ya quand même beaucoup
plus de courant donc pour nager tu dois
faire plus d'efforts et donc tu
consommes plus d'oxygène après 30
minutes lydia commence à être faibles
niveaux d'oxygène et elle fait donc
signe à son instructeur qu'elle
s'apprête à remonter
alors rassurez vous son niveau d'oxygène
est loin d'être critique mais en plongée
on est très prudent et on s'y prend
vachement en avance elle s'apprête donc
à remonter mais elle aperçoit au loin un
jeune homme nager vers elle ce jeune
homme sénile instructeur ni un camarade
du court mais hélas un équipement
complet de plongée donc des bouteilles
un masque une combinaison comme tous les
élèves du groupe arrivé à côté de lydia
le jeune homme lui fais le signe que tu
dois faire quand tu n'as plus d'oxygène
lydia temps donc son appareil de
rechange à ce jeune homme et à partir de
là puisqu'ils sont maintenant 2 à
respirer dans les bouteilles de lydia
bas le niveau d'oxygène restantes
descent 2 fois plus vite
lydia attend que le jeune homme se calme
parce qu'il avait l'air quand même en
panique et puis à lui fait signe d'aller
voir l'instructeur qui est probablement
beaucoup plus qualifiés qu'elles pour
lui porter assistance mais le jeune
homme fait non avec la tête et lui fait
signe d' entamer sa remontée et puis
aussitôt il se met à remonter et attirer
donc lydia avec lui lydia comprend pas
trop ce qui se passe puisque ça aurait
pris que 20 secondes d'aller prévenir
l'instructeur que la panne des rétais
proche et que l
en train d'aider ce jeune homme mais
elle est en train de remonter malgré
elle à la surface avec ce mec
et puis en tournant la tête elle voit
que son instructeur nage vers el sayeh
il l'a repéré et c'est à ce moment là
que le jeune homme inconnu lâche lydia
se remet à utiliser son propre
équipement de plongée et semé à nager à
toute vitesse au loin lydia ne comprends
pas mais son instructeur et maintenant à
ses côtés et l'accompagnent dans son
ascension vers la surface
arrivés sur le bateau lydia et un peu
choqués de ce qui vient de se passer est
donc elle demande à son instructeur qui
était ce mec et son instructeur lui
répond que c'était probablement un mec
qui a perdu son groupe de plongée et
qu'ils avaient besoin juste d'un peu de
temps pour se calmer bref incident un
peu bizarre et le lendemain lydia
retourne donc plongé cette fois avec sa
famille et aussi une instructrice
charlie et elle va immédiatement ce
jour-là parler à charlie des incidents
de la veille
charlie demande à lydia de lui décrire
cet homme et elle lui dit reconnaître
cette description puisqu'il s'agit de
celle de marvin un mec qui bosse dans un
restaurant de la ville et qui sur ses
jours de congés va tout le temps faire
de la plongée puisqu'il aimerait devenir
instructeur
ce jour-là charlie a même mangé à ce
restaurant le midi et elle a vu marvin
il est donc envie tout va bien il a pu
remonter à la surface la bei est notre
ami lydia est donc rassuré les jours
passent les plongées passe tout se passe
bien lydia commence à prendre au niveau
et durant tout est plongée lydia l'a pas
recroiser marvin sous l'eau sauf le
dernier jour ce jour là c'est le dernier
jour de plongée et donc ils ont planifié
un sacré truc pour l'occasion ils vont
plonger dans une épave
l'épave est située à 30 mètres de
profondeur donc c'est une profondeur
assez importante
on est donc sur une plongée beaucoup
plus techniques que celles auxquelles
lydia est habitué puisqu'il ya des
paliers de décompression sommes prêts si
vous avez vu cette vidéo vous comprenez
tout ce que je dis bref ils descendent à
30 mètres ils sont impressionnés par
l'épave qui se trouve devant eux
lydia croiser deux fois l'instructeur
les deux fois et lui demande si tout va
bien elle lui fait signe que oui et
c'est peu de temps après qu'elle
aperçoit au loin marvin nager vers elle
à ce moment précis lydia est à 25 mètres
de profondeur elle est donc encore en
dessous son arrêt de décompression
obligatoire si elle veut revenir à la
surface
en voyant marvin elle est un peu
surprise et puis après quelques secondes
il attrape le bras de lydia et commence
à la tirer vers le haut lydia ne
comprend pas ce qui se passe
elle est tétanisée et puis elle se met à
s'agiter dans tous les sens en espérant
que son père ou de ses soeurs qui sont
plusieurs mètres en dessous d'elle à ce
moment-là lève la tête et comprennent ce
qui se passe et lorsqu elle s'apprête à
dépasser son palier de décompression
elle sans une main
trapé la cheville et cette mince et
celle de son père il la tire alors vers
le bas pour qu'elle s'éloigne le plus
possible de son palier de décompression
et face à marvin lâche lydia et nage au
loin à toute vitesse de retour à la
surface lydia est traumatisée elle est
en pleurs elle comprend pas ce qui vient
de se passer elle comprend pas pourquoi
marvin elle ce comportement là mais elle
va obtenir les réponses à ces questions
le lendemain car le lendemain elle passe
une dernière fois au bureau du club de
plongée parce que ses soeurs doivent
récupérer leur diplôme en arrivant au
bureau elle tombe sur charlie la
deuxième instructrice qui lui avait
expliqué que l'inconnu était marvin qui
travaillait au restaurant elle lui
raconte les événements mais charlie ne
comprend pas puisque la veille elle
était au restaurant au travail marvin et
marvin était là en fait lydia c'est pas
marvin qu'elle a croisés sous l'eau
c'est un parfaite inconnue que les
instructeurs ne connaissais pas et qui
n'appartenait à aucun groupe de plongée
de lille elle comprend donc qu'en fait
ce mec il a un kiff quand il plonge
c'est d'aller voir des novices et
d'essayer de les buts est tout
simplement soit en les forçant à ne pas
respecter leurs paliers de décompression
soit en tirant sur leur oxygène pour
entraîner une bonne mère elle a donc
rapporté tout ça à la police sauf que
c'est quand même sacrément improbable et
elle n'a plus jamais revu cet inconnu
qui peut-être s'en est pris à d'autres
plongeurs novices de la même manière
alors cette histoire je les aime bien
parce que sur terre il se passe des
trucs relou mais sous l'eau battue n'est
pas tranquille non plus je suis désolé
mais ayant peur en milieu sous marin
cette histoire elle me terrifie j'ai
fait de la plongée plusieurs fois et mon
gars si ça m'était arrivé mais je crois
j'aurais fait une crise cardiaque sous
l'eau mais vraiment
bref passons à la deuxième histoire et
cette fois ça se passe sur la terre
ferme et cette histoire c'est celle de
claudia claudia à 16 ans au moment où
elle raconte les faits mais l'histoire a
eu lieu quatre ans avant quand elle en
avait douze l'ami doit elle va parler
dans cette histoire à deux ans de plus
qu'elle donc à l'époque elle avait 14 et
cette amie elle s'appelle salut elle
prend le temps de préciser qu'à cet
âge-là deux ans d'écart c'est quand même
beaucoup s'adonnent quelqu'un qui en 4e
au collège et qui est ami avec quelqu'un
qui en seconde au lycée c'est plutôt
rare de voir ça en réalité mais elles
elles sont copines on est vendredi si le
début de la soirée et tout se passe bien
tout est ordinaire comme tous les
vendredis qu'elles ont passées ensemble
auparavant et comme très souvent elles
sont toutes les deux chez salies ce
soir-là claudia et ça les regarde
hunger games et puis après le film elle
traîne dans la chambre de sa vie elle
met de la musique elle s'amuse à se
préparer à semer cup et c'est comme si
elle allait aller à une soirée
bref elle imite les grandes et c'est là
que tout va partir en vrille
il faut savoir que sally c'est pas
vraiment une influence positive elle est
décrit par claudia comme étant une
manipulatrice et comme la rabaissant
très souvent pour elle se met en avant
classique truc du collège ou de twitter
et parmi ces défauts elle avait entre
autres le vilain fait de parler à des
hommes beaucoup plus âgés cale sur des
sites de rencontres et de mentir sur son
âge à elle ce soir là elle montre à
claudia quelques textos qu'elle a eue
avec un inconnu il ya un truc qui
l'interpellent dans les échanges c'est
que le mec en face fait tout pour
rencontrer sa vie ce mec aurait d'après
ce qu'il dit dans les messages 19 ans et
ils seraient grands blonds et aux yeux
bleus
waouh on est dans un disney après avoir
lu les messages claudia demande donc à
saly si elle a une photo de lui bonne
nouvelle salle y en a une sauf que
l'homme qui est sur la photo n'a
clairement pas 19 ans il ya plus 40 ans
bref les heures passent et sally reçoit
un appel de cet homme elle le met sur
haut parleur pour que claudia puisse
entendre et l'homme va lui dire qu'elle
est vraiment belle et qu'il aimerait
qu'il se rencontre sally elle va lui
dire la vérité
elle va lui dire écoute tu avec une pote
la tranquille on passe une petite soirée
pyjama on se régale
et ça ça va intriguer l'inconnu au bout
du fil il va donc proposer à saly de
venir avec son ami tient plus on est de
fous plus on rigole
le plan est donc le suivant sally veut
que l et claudia face le mur et se
rendent furtivement là où l'homme leur a
demandé à savoir sur le parking désert
d'un mcdo support of comme plante soirée
pour être honnête claudia évidemment
elle veut vraiment pas y aller elle sans
qu un autre qui va pas sauf qu'elle voit
bien que sally va y aller
quoi qu'il arrive donc elle va décider
de l'accompagner au cas où les choses
tourneraient mal mais elle a tellement
un mauvais pressentiment qu'elle va
cacher un couteau de cuisine dans son
soutien gorge
juste au cas où
sympa l'ambiance de ce rendez vous bref
elles partent en douce de la maison
elles ont leur téléphone avec elle sur
le chemin il ya peu lampadaires donc
elles sont déjà en flip avant même
d'arriver sur le parking et en arrivant
sur le parking une voiture est garée une
toyota corolla 2009 et a déjà un hic il
ya plusieurs personnes dans cette
voiture l'homme de la photo ouvre la
porte du siège passager et sort de la
voiture étant à quelques mètres de la
voiture et leur demande de s'approcher
lui claudia allume le flash de son
téléphone pour mieux voir et grâce à son
flash
elle voit que le mec face à elle est
complètement sous drogue il a les yeux
plus que globuleux et surtout il est
nerveux ils n'arrêtent pas de trembler
il s'approcha lors de nos deux amis et
tout de suite il attrape le bras de
salies immédiatement claudia dégaine le
couteau qu'elle a dans son soutien-gorge
et face à ça les amis du mec sortent
tous de la voiture ils vont essayer de
calmer le jeu en leur proposant de
monter dans la voiture voiture dans
laquelle il aurait apparemment de
l'alcool et de la drogue claudia elle
trouve ça pas cool du tout elle a son
téléphone dans la main et leur dit
qu'elle est prête à appeler la police
sur ces mots l'inconnue de la photo
lâche le bras de salies et cette fois
c'est claudia qui attrape le bras de
samy et qui part en courant avec elle
elle arrive saine et sauve à la maison
familiale est immédiatement ça lui prend
son téléphone et supprime le mec de tous
ces réseaux
elle passe la nuit à regarder aux
fenêtres et elles font bien puisqu'elles
vont apercevoir à multiples reprises une
toyota corolla 2009 rodez le jour se
lève
elles n'ont pas dormi de la nuit claudia
rentrent chez elles et c'est tout elles
en ont jamais parlé à leurs parents et
le lendemain s'allie à reprocher à
claudia de lui avoir gâché sa soirée et
du coup elles se sont plus parlés
pendant trois ans heureusement le hasard
fait que sally a déménagé quelques mois
plus tard mais claudia n'a jamais eu
aussi peur que ce soir-là et l'injustice
fait qu'elle a perdu sa meilleure pote
pour lui avoir sauvé la vie géniale
n'allez pas à des rendez vous avec des
inconnus des inconnus qui ont 20 ans
alors vous en avez 14
ça suffit ça c'est un truc de ouf quand
tu es jeune ya un effet horrible c'est
que tindall a vachement les gens plus
vieux et ubs vachement ta garde face à
eux sauf qu'en fait plus un mec wind of
ages et s'intéresse à toi qui est très
jeune la hâte en 12 et 14 ans et mega
jeunes plus c'est très mauvais signe
enfin il n'y a même pas de débat et
c'est là qu'on voit toute la différence
entre quelqu'un comme claudia qui a été
sensibilisée à ça et quelqu'un comme
salis qui n'a pas spécialement été et
c'est terrible en fait voilà si vous
êtes jeune et que vous regardez cette
vidéo déjà cessé troc répit pour vous
qu'est ce que vous faites là allez
plutôt voir cette vidéo est ensuite
faites gaffe prenez soin de vous
mais les temps de passer à la troisième
et dernière histoire de cette vidéo
horrible c'est celle de clarisse et
autant vous dire que cette histoire je
la trouve affreuse parce que nous les
mecs c'est un secret pour personne
on a de la chance sur ça on en cours
beaucoup moins de danger mais sachez que
même en étant un mec il ya des
situations comme ça où j'ai peur donc
j'imagine même pas si j'étais une meuf
clarisse elle n'est pas française elle
vit aux états unis à portland
précisément et l'histoire qu'elle
raconte a eu lieu en 2018 bref ce
soir-là clarisse est sortie elle est
avec des amis dans un bar y danse et il
se met une giga caisse en fait à
l'époque elle a compris qu'elle pouvait
faire des économies en ne mangeant pas
avant d'aller une soirée parce que du
coup elle pouvait se mettre une méga
caisson buvant beaucoup moins d'alcool à
clarisse élevé en soirée pour en
découdre ce soir là elle est tellement
ivre qu'à la fin de la soirée elle se
souvient à peine d'avoir demandé à son
ami du a pris un hubert bref ses amis
l'amène jusqu'à la voiture lui souhaite
une bonne nuit et leurs chemins se
séparent quelques minutes après le début
du trajet le conducteur demande à
clarisse comment s'est passée sa soirée
et d'une demande aussi si elles fument
alors comme moi vous comprenez tous fin
sauf les chauffeurs du coup que quand tu
es dans cet état tu as envie de tout
sauf de parler aux conducteurs tu veux
parler à ton lit et à personne d'autre
du coup elle esquive la discussion
quelques minutes plus tard clarisse et
surprise parce que le conducteur du
temps un jour aucun clarisse comprend
pas et elle lui dit écoute je veux juste
rentrer chez moi et dormir et le
chauffeur lui réponds que c'est un joint
à base d'un 10 kg klein dit qu'à ça
permet de bien dormir
encore une fois clarisse elle est dans
cette situation relou tu sais pas trop
quoi répondre ce que tu as peur
d'énerver le mec donc tu dis ni oui ni
non juste esquive mai et on esquive elle
est perçue par le mec comme un merci
pour le joint je vais tirer dessus dans
un instant geoffrey va donc lui dire bon
pas de souci si tu veux fumer mais par
contre je dois annuler la course parce
que je peux pas te donner le joint tant
que je suis en course ça n'a aucun sens
et clarisse elle est bourrée mais elle
comprend direct que ça n'a aucun sens
et au moment où elle s'apprête à dire
quelque chose elle voit qui vient
d'annuler la course et qui vient de se
garer aux alentours c'est que des
parkings vides un atelier de carrosserie
fermée
bref y'a personne à la ronde le
chauffeur va donc allumé juin et à
chaque fois qu'il le temps à clarisse
elle le prend et elle fait semblant de
tirer dessus elle grapotte dans le but
de pas l'énerver et provoqué aucune
réaction incontrôlée de sa part
bref un grand silence dans la voiture
clarisse relève les yeux vers le
rétroviseur et elle croise le regard du
chauffeur qui est en train de la fixer
chauffeur qui lui dit on est bien ici
clarisse ludique c'était cool mais
qu'elle va appeler un autre ibère pour
rentrer chez elle mais le chauffeur lui
dit d'un ton gadjé toujours ton adresse
je vais te ramener clarisse relativise
elle se dit peut-être qu'elle se fait
des films que le chauffeur c'était juste
un gros fumeur de windchill et qu elle
réagi de manière excessive
non clarisse tu n'as rien fait de mal à
chauffeur n'est pas censée s'arrêter
annuler la course et fumé un joint avec
toi c'est pas ta faute là bref la
voiture démarre et le trajet reprend à
l'époque larry elle vit dans un campus
qui est située au sud-ouest du
centre-ville sur la gauche il ya plein
de pompes qui permettent de passer au
dessus de la rivière et de rejoindre le
centre ville et donc le sud-ouest du
centre-ville mais la voiture passe à
côté tout ces ponts et d'empreintes
aucun c'est la quatrième sortie que la
voiture aurait dû emprunter pour se
rendre au centre ville
mais la voiture continue de rouler vers
le nord et au détail qui a son
importance au nord est du centre ville
c'est que des zones désaffectée un gros
que des endroits isolés où il ya
personne clarisse elle comprend que là
c'est vraiment chaud elle prend son élan
et elle dit au chauffeur que son petit
ami l'attend à la maison face à ça le
chauffeur ne dit rien mais il fait demi
tour et il prend une sortie qui mène au
centre-ville à partir de là il ya de
longues minutes qui vont s'écouler sans
qu'aucun des deux ne s'échangent le
moindre mot mais clarisse elle est loin
d'être sereine et elle a la main sur la
poignée de la porte et elle raconte qu'à
chaque feu rouge elle est prête à
l'ouvrir et à partir en cours finalement
la voiture arive à deux pâtés de maison
de l'appartement de clarisse
elle lui met la classique au dos du
arrêtez-vous là c'est plus simple parce
qu'elle veut juste pas qu'ils voient où
elle habite et il lui répond pas mais il
s'arrête
clarisse est soulagée elle a même un
sourire aux lèves alors elle appuie sur
le bouton de la porte pour sortir mais
la porte s'ouvre pas elle soulève alors
le petit truc manuel la de verrouillage
mais ils bougent pas la porte est bel et
bien verrouillé et en levant la tête
elle voit le chauffeur qui a la tête
complètement tourné vers elle et qui lui
sourit elle explique que c'est le pire
sourire qu'il n'a jamais vu de sa vie
que le mec était vraiment en train
d'apprécier en fait de lui faire peur et
immédiatement clarisse fond en larmes et
le supplie d'ouvrir la porte et après
quelques secondes
le chauffeur déverrouille la porte
clarisse sort de la voiture cours
jusqu'à chez elle et en arrivant dans
son appartement elle s'aperçoit que son
petit ami n'était pas là puisqu'il était
en fait sorti avec des amis à lui au
dernier moment en fait ce soir là
personne n'attendait clarisse et
personne n'aurait eu aucun signe qui lui
était arrivé malheur avant un bon moment
la nuit passée en se réveillant
lendemain clarisse elle réalise toujours
pas en fait elle qu'elle comprend
toujours pas si c'est elle qu'on a fait
des caisses et que le mec était
totalement inoffensifs ou si il
représentait vraiment un danger et quoi
qu'il en soit que l'aristo chauffeur n'a
pas à faire ça qu'elle présente un
danger ou pas on s'en fout mais en tout
cas s'arrêter sur un parking et te
forcer a tiré sur un joint c'est pas
normal et c'est ça me rend fou dans les
histoires comme ça ou envers les gens
vivent des trucs horribles et ils sont
dix sont des victimes dans leur histoire
clairement et ils remettent tout le
temps en doute le fait d'être une
victime y pense tout le temps que
peut-être qu'ils ont imaginé des choses
peut-être que c'est pas
on ne renie pas les faits tu as en cours
et un danger clarisse et a super bien
agi bravo clarisse mois congratulations
carolis elle comprendra pas si je dis
bravo
bon c'est la bonne ce serait dommage
j'espère qu'il vous a plu la plongée
c'est terminé les lumières se terminer
pour nous les soirées pyjama à 13 ans
est terminée pour nous bref prenez soin
de vous attribuer dans une prochaine
vidéo ça va faire du sport là c'est
comment je fais le mec je mange de
lancer rock'n'chic
[Musique]